wenn ich mir auf instagram yoga posts
anschaue frage ich mich erstens würde
das jetzt mit selbstauslöser gemacht
oder war das ein organisierter fotoshoot
und zweitens ist das alles nur ein hype
oder bringt yoga wirklich was ich will
in diesem video der frage nachgehen hat
yoga gesundheitliche vorteile
körperliche wie psychische die wirklich
wissenschaftlich nachgewiesen sind und
soviel kann ich schon mal verraten die
forschung hat mich ziemlich überrascht
doch neben der theorie gibt es natürlich
auch einen praxistest und zwar mit
unserer rasenden reporterin saadet
sie denn sich selbst
für uns hat sie drei verschiedene yoga
arten getestet welche davon die beste
ist und was die wissenschaft dazu sagt
das klären wir jetzt
[Musik]
erstmal was ist yoga überhaupt ein wenig
an yoga denke dann denke ich irgendwie
an pure entspannung an ein bisschen
vielleicht sogar so karibik muss ich so
viel rauschen ich und mein inneres ich
befinden zusammen ich dachte irgendwie
yoga das ist da legt man sich ein
bisschen so
sein oder was auch immer man versucht
eine kurze definition von yoga zu finden
stellt man fest also kurze schwierig ist
natürlich ein sehr weites feld das ist
holger krahmer erst psychologe und
forschungsleiter an der klinik für
naturheilkunde und integrative medizin
in essen also naturheilkunde und
integrative medizin klingt für eine 08
15 chemikerin ungewohnt aber da es bei
meiner recherche auf einige interessante
studien von holger krahmer gestoßen den
dachte ich ich schreibe ihnen einfach
mal an yoga bis heute meist praktiziert
wird umfasst vor allem die bekannten
logo haltung sondern da saß ein sehr
unterschiedliche ausprägung das kann
sehr sanft sein auch wenn bisher
sportlich und zwar oft sportlicher als
es scheint ich dachte eigentlich von mir
ich wäre es nicht die unsportlichste
kartoffel offenen von planeten aber wir
waren so übungen beide dann doch ganz
schön schwierig waren zu halten und so
in die anderen seien dabei alle so
entspannt aus ich halt irgendwie nicht
ich habe mal richtig ins schwitzen
gekommen neben dem bewegungs aspekt
umfasst yoga auch spezielle atem und
meditationstechnik die atemtechniken
werden als pranayama bezeichnet yoga
kann allerdings total viel umfassen
jetzt nach indien vor allem gucken also
yoga ist eine sehr starke spirituelle
konnotation ist stammt ursprünglich aus
der indischen philosophie und
spiritualität und es dann aber durch den
kontakt auch mit den besten auch in
indien sehr stark zu einer
gesundheitspraxis
gesundheitspraxis holger krahmer
untersucht yoga als zusatztherapie bei
verschiedenen krankheiten was steckt
dahinter was super spannend ist ist die
ganze forschung zur atmung und
gesundheit und könnte ja meinen atmen
ist so eine grundlegende überlebens
funktion was kann man da schon viel
falsch oder richtig machen wir atmen
manchmal zu flach zu schnell oder zu
viel durch den mund vor allem wenn wir
gestresst sind es ist wirklich was dran
an der empfehlung bei stress erst mal
ruhig durchzuatmen zum beispiel in einer
prüfung vor einem wichtigen vortrag das
atmung nicht nur luft holen ist sondern
einfluss auf unser nervensystem hat ist
inzwischen wissenschaftlich ganz gut
belegt man jetzt sehr speziell in die
atmung eingreift wie es im yoga der fall
ist kann man relativ viele
psychologische system aufsetzen können
zum beispiel gezeigt werden dass
bestimmte atemtechniken
neurotransmitter im gehirn stimulieren
können zum beispiel kann man mit
buttersäure ist anfang
buttersäure kurz gabe ist ein
neurotransmitter das heißt ein
signalmolekül das gehirnaktivitäten
runter regelt oder hemmt die hemmende
wirkung von gaba ist ziemlich wichtig
für unser gehirn also dass wir aktive
die hier in zell brauchen das ist klar
aber auf der anderen seite sind wir so
vielen reizen ausgesetzt dass es ohne
gabe eine völlige reizüberflutung wäre
wir werden gar nicht mehr dazu in der
lage informationen zu ordnen oder
zwischen verschiedenen reizen zu
differenzieren diese hemmung durch gabe
braucht unser gieren auch um ich sag mal
zu verhindern dass schaltkreise im
gehirn übersteuern und sozusagen eine
rückkopplung entsteht das passiert
nämlich bei einem epileptischen anfall
deswegen werden bei epilepsie auch
medikamente eingesetzt die die gaba
konzentration erhöhen das yoga über die
atem übungen und gabe erhöhen auch bei
epilepsie helfen könnte dafür gibt es
bisher keine belastbaren
wissenschaftlichen daten doch gabe hat
viele funktionen zum beispiel hilft es
uns nicht nur bei der konzentration
sondern auch bei der entspannung und
deswegen spielt es auch eine rolle bei
krankheiten die mit stress in verbindung
stehen zum beispiel bluthochdruck stress
senkt den gala spiegel yoga kann ihn
wieder erhöhen yoga kann zwar nicht
alleine eine wirksame therapie gegen
bluthochdruck sein aber als
zusatztherapie zu konventionellen
methoden also zu entsprechenden
medikamenten kann yoga durchaus helfen
so gibt es hier einige randomisierte
kontrollierte studien in denen yoga als
zusatztherapie den blutdruck weiter
senken unsere atmung kann außerdem auch
unsere kognitiven leistungen
beeinflussen das neue
forschungsergebnisse zeigen dass atmung
und die hier zum schwingen bringt also
lange dachte man dass diese schwankungen
kinder konnten sind aber jetzt hat man
gezeigt dass atmung die aktivität der
gesamten großhirnrinde synchronisiert
und dass diese aktivität unserem
atemrhythmus folgt dieser studie zeigt
dass atmung sogar unsere merkfähigkeit
beeinflusst die studienteilnehmer
bekamen in der ersten fall das
experiment 180 verschiedene bilder zu
sehen wie jeweils eine halbe sekunde die
sie sich möglichst gut merken soll nach
20 minuten pause bekamen die teilnehmer
in einer zweiten phase wieder ganz viele
bilder gezeigt und zwar eine mischung
aus den bereits gezeigten bildern aus
phase 1 und neuen bildern und die
teilnehmer mussten jetzt die gemerkten
bilder unter den neuen wiedererkennen
und es ist voll krass es stellte sich
heraus dass die teilnehmer in phase eins
sich die bilder dann besonders gut
merken konnten weil die bilder zum
zeitpunkt des einatmens erschienen vor
allem wenn die teilnehmer durch die nase
einatmen abgefahren oder der studien
belegen natürlich nicht die wirksamkeit
von atemübungen beim yoga aber ich finde
sie zeigen überraschend deutlich das
atmen mehr ist also luft holen deshalb
ist es zumindest plausibel dass man beim
yoga versucht entspannung oder mehr zu
gewinnen indem man atmen bewusst übt das
atmen geübt sein will das merkt man
schnell wenn man sich mal an einer atem
besucht war der atem meditation
konzentriert man sich ganz auf seine
atmung auf das heben und senken von
bauch und brust auf die luft wie sie ein
und ausströmt und auf sonst nichts
anderes und das ist schwieriger als es
klingt anfängern empfiehlt man zum
beispiel seine atemzüge zu zählen damit
man nicht vielleicht abschweift
2 sobald man in andere gedanken
abschweift fängt man wieder von vorne
nach das mal und schreibt man bitte in
die kommentare wie viele atemzüge ihr
geschafft hat ohne an was anderes zu
denken es ist erstaunlich jährige
konzentriert zu bleiben nennt guard
verrate ich euch noch eine weitere art
im übung die ihr in stress situationen
anwenden könnt aber gehen wir jetzt
erstmal vom atem weg beziehungsweise
weiter was ist mit den ganzen yoga posen
mit den asanas welchen zweck haben die
eigentlich ja zunächst einmal ist yoga
auch bewegung und je nachdem was für den
kurs man belegt auch richtig sport da
sagte der sonst sportlicher unterwegs
ist hat sie sich drei verschiedene eher
sportliche yogakurse rausgesucht einmal
traditionelles ashtanga yoga
also es war eine super angenehmer
atmosphäre in diesem yogastudio wir
kommen da rein und es war dann lief die
ganze zeit so ein bisschen musik im
hintergrund und alle waren super nett
und lieb und haben auch irgendwie so ein
gerede
ungewohnt für mich
entspannt nicht anstrengen dann einmal
hot yoga
und einmalige yoga auf die gehen wir
jeweils auch gleich noch genauer ein
dass bewegung gut ist wissen wir ja bei
chronischen rückenschmerzen ist bewegung
eine konventionelle therapie zum
beispiel physiotherapie oder stretching
und hier hat sich gezeigt dass yoga mit
den konventionellen methoden ganz gut
mithalten kann also eine ernst zu
nehmende therapie alternative ist aber
jura ist nicht einfach nur eine art von
sport oder bewegung oder macht es
irgendeinen unterschied ob ich bestimmte
asanas ausführen oder irgendwelche
gymnastik bewegungen mache zumindest
kann man im vergleich zu vielen anderen
sportarten feststellen dass die
yogaübungen oft gar nicht so furchtbar
intensiv sind dass man oft in dem
bereich ist wo man sagt es reicht noch
nicht um es als herz kreislauf training
zu klassifizieren
also zu geringe intensität um zu sagen
das herz kreislauf system mit genug
angelegt um zu sagen das ist ein
wirksames training ist trotzdem also
dass der revolution folgen als kreislauf
risikofaktoren das heißt irgendwas muss
da drin sein was uns auswirkt wenn die
bewegung eigentlich gar nicht intensive
woche einen ähnlichen effekt stellte
holger krahmer fest bei einer studie zu
yoga und gewichtsabnahme und zeigen kann
ist durch yoga
wichtige teilnehmer werden nicht
reduzieren können bauchumfang abnehmen
und wenn man das mal aus rechnet ist das
alles gar nicht intensiv genug um
wirklich eine sprechende
kalorienreduktion hinzubekommen dass
diese gewichtsabnahme sein dürfte das
heißt da scheint offenbar auch dann die
meditation verändertes essverhalten das
acht tage dann geht eine rolle zu
spielen der bewegungs aspekt lässt sich
also schwer von anderen yoga aspekten
trennen aber vielleicht ist genau
deswegen yoga so positiv weil es eben
nicht nur bewegung oder nur meditation
ist sondern ein gesamten lebensstil
beeinflussen kann der potentielle
anwendungsbereich von yoga als therapie
ist jedenfalls erstaunlich groß bei
depressionen zum beispiel wenn man
darauf kommt weiß man dass bewegung bei
depressionen generell gut ist und es
gibt auch gute hinweise dass meditation
helfen kann so dass es ein yoga als
kombination eigentlich auch wiederum
rechtens ist wenn wir in sehr
schwerwiegende neuropsychiatrischen
störungen kommen reicht sogar
wahrscheinlich nicht auch im bereich der
depression haben wir sehr gute hinweise
mit sehr starken effekt stärkung bei
leichten depressiven störungen weil man
die feste barrieren depression also
wirklich klinisch manifesten depression
ist sogar wahrscheinlich nicht auch der
einsatz bei krebspatienten vor allem bei
brustkrebspatienten wird vier
untersuchten also ganz wichtig wenn man
sich krebs anguckt ist das yoga
eigentlich nie zur behandlung des krebs
eingesetzt wie er das studium drehen
sich immer darum mit symptomen der
krebserkrankungen oder auch mit
nebenwirkungen der therapie also der
chemotherapie zum beispiel umzugehen
jura hat also potenzial als
begleittherapie bei krebs das heißt es
geht vor allem um milderung von
nebenwirkungen oder symptomen um ein
gesteigertes wohlbefinden um
stressreduktion und so weiter viele
krebspatienten brechen tatsächlich ihre
therapie ab weil sie die nebenwirkungen
nicht mehr aushalten wenn man es schafft
diese nebenwirkungen zu mildern dann
kann das über den therapieerfolg
entscheiden dieses problem haben wir
schon bei unserem video über den
placebo-effekt anklingen lassen deswegen
wirklich schon dass der grundansatz
dieser klinik also konventionelle
medizin therapie anwenden aber durch
zusatz methoden wie zum beispiel yoga
vergessen dass das durchaus wirksam sein
kann dass das so viel yoga forschung zu
brustkrebs und nicht zu anderen
krebsarten gibt liegt übrigens nicht an
der krebsart an sich sondern daran dass
die typischen yoga an unser meist
jüngere frauen sind was auch dann
häufiger die populationen sind die und
brustkrebs erkrankt so ist es auch
einfach eine höhere nachfrage ist also
mehr frauen mit brustkrebs zb den nutzen
yoga und fragen nur nach als ältere
männer mit darmkrebs die können sich
durchaus nicht so angesprochen und
generell ist krebs in vielen bereichen
deutlich besser als andere krebs
entitäten beides weil auch von den
patienten gibt sehr große bewegungen es
gibt es ein großes selbsthilfegruppen
die auf forschung gerade in dem bereich
einfordern es gibt wirklich viele
studien zu yoga und gesundheit aber was
mich stört ist dass die meisten
methodisch ziemlich warm ich sind
dadurch auch ein ganz wunden punkt der
yoga forschung gefunden es ist natürlich
immer in der klinischen forschung das
ideal des tollen linden san siro
kontrollierten medikament als treue
freunde der sonne wissen natürlich wie
von holger krahmer verspricht und kann
in yoga studien natürlich
kontrollgruppen haben also man kann
teilnehmer vergleichen die yoga stunden
bekommen mit teilnehmern die keine
bekommen aber natürlich kriegt man hier
keine verblendungen also nicht wie bei
medikamenten und placebos wo die
studienteilnehmer nicht wissen ob sie
einen wirkstoff bekommen oder nicht
ausserdem sind die yoga interventionen
also die art und weise wie genau an
diesen studien angewendet wird von
studien zu studie total unterschiedlich
wie yoga intervention hängt sehr stark
vom zentrum akkus durchgeführt wurde vom
video gerade dabei ist zum teil auch von
den wissenschaftlern die eigene vor
erfahrung haben und da haben wir sehr
unterschiedliche yoga form und das ist
natürlich schwierig meiner seite passt
alles zusammen deshalb kann man von dem
aktuellen stand der yoga forschung nicht
davon ausgehen dass eine positive
wirkung auf konkrete yoga posen
zurückzuführen ist vielmehr muss man
davon ausgehen dass yoga als form von
bewegung ähnlich wie andere form der
bewegung gesund ist und hier jetzt auch
noch gepaart mit stressreduktion durch
atemübungen
meditationsübungen und wahrscheinlich
auch einem allgemeinen achtsamen
entspannteren lifestyle was ist dann mit
so krasseren yoga formen wie hot yoga
einem hot yoga oder bikram yoga beginnt
man sich in einem 40 grad heißen raum
also erst hat mich der erste stark
getroffen als ich mich im raum rhein
gegangen bin und man so wirklich so von
dem band gelaufen ist so wandern war
schon nach dem aufwärmen übungen habe
ich geschwitzt also und zwar so richtig
des 26 bestimmte asanas werden hier in
einer bestimmten reihenfolge durch
praktiziert und jetzt den arm nach oben
sind noch und nutzt das und das und das
und es war richtig schnell
hintereinander
das war ja meine erste stunde deswegen
gleich komplett übervoller das sieht man
auch irgendwie habe ich ständig die
sache nicht da hingekriegt wo sie hin
mussten und habe mich in mir selber
verknotet und währenddessen die ganze
zeit sehr viel geschwitzt entspannt
sieht es jedenfalls nicht aussah als
trainer erklärt uns dass der anfang zwar
schwer sei aber durch das verinnerlichen
der reihenfolge und den strikten ablauf
käme man auch in eine art meditativen
zustand
gibt einzelne studien mittlerweile die
auch zeigen können dass wir tatsächlich
wirksam ist bei patienten mit
herzerkrankungen ist die gefäße dass die
zieht erhöhte system kann um die studie
allerdings methodische mängel also die
will ich auch durchaus hinterfragen für
mich ist es bisher nicht überzeugend das
ist wirklich ein herz kreislauf
förderliche wirkung hat und ich werde
durchaus vorsichtig das medizinisch
vorerkrankungen patienten sollen während
sowieso nicht mehr forschung aber ich
will doch jetzt kollegen nicht unbedingt
raten ich bin sehr zu empfehlen dadurch
ist die datenlage also zu bringen in
dieser kleinen studie diesmal ein
teilnehmer drei monate lang hot yoga
praktizieren also damit meine ich diese
26 assayas nur einmal in einem heißen
raum und einmal in einem normal
temperierten raum die heiße gruppe hatte
zwar nach diesem experiment weniger
körperfett aber in sachen
gefäßgesundheit und elastizität hat man
keinen unterschied zwischen den beiden
gruppen allerdings sah man bei beiden
gruppen eine verbesserung gegenüber der
kontrollgruppe die gar kein junger
machte sollten sich diese ergebnisse in
weiteren untersuchungen bestätigen hieße
das dass die
kardiovaskuläre wirkung von hot yoga gar
nichts mit der hort nichts zu tun hat
was mit sicherheit bei hohen
temperaturen besser geht es in gewisse
unterhaltungen reinzukommen dass man
also
vermeintlich flexibel agiert ist man es
gelenkiger und kommt besser in spiel
yoga haltung wobei das aber
wahrscheinlich ein trugschluss ist dass
man halt gar nicht wirklich gelenkigen
vier sondern einfach nur der widerstand
reagierten trotzdem die gelenke genau so
überlastet wenn man jetzt ein extrem
teil in dem motto sitz in
temperierten räumen nicht rein kommt
aber in dem starke hintzen raum würde
man nicht leicht rein kommen weil man
einfach das ganze gewebe einfach ein
bisschen beweglicher wird ist die
belastung zu dürfte genauso groß es
wurden bisher keine gefährlichen
nebenwirkungen oder risiken von hot yoga
festgestellt so lange das wichtig man
gesund ist und natürlich auch ganz
wichtig solange man genug trinkt junge
gesunde sportliche menschen die können
das mit sicherheit ausprobieren gut das
sah dass jung gesund und sportlich ist
doch es muss ja noch nicht mal hot yoga
seien nur etwas entspannt aussieht und
für die meisten auch entspannend ist
muss es nicht frei von risiken seien
holger krahmer beschäftigt sich in
letzter zeit vermehrt mit risiken und
unerwünschten nebenwirkungen von yoga es
gibt eine ganz spezielle warnung war
yoga und zwar für alle die unter einem
grünen star oder glaukom leiden stahl
liegt an der abschluss störung im aus
vor und deshalb dass der augeninnendruck
sich immer mehr erhöht und bei
unterhaltung oder kopfstand beim
schulter stand zum beispiel ist auch
mittlerweile nachgewiesen dass ich da
auch der augeninnendruck erhöht so dass
patienten mit einer vorgeschichte von
glaukom da gebe ich eine verschlimmerung
sachen können ist weil es bis zur
erblindung führen kann dass unser auch
nicht trivial los davon abgesehen gibt
es beim yoga genau wie bei anderen
sportarten oder bewegungen eine
verletzungsgefahr wenn man die
bewegungen falsch ausführt nur diese
verletzungsgefahr da nicht so stark vom
nova stil ab also man konnte sehen dass
power yoga sondern sehr intensive yoga
praxis wieder doch auch eher so als
workout genutzt wird ein bisschen
höheres verletzungsrisiko hat ansonsten
sind die relativ ähnlich was wir aber
sehen konnten ist das verletzungsrisiko
steigt wenn menschen yoga üben ohne
vorher bei einem yoga lehrende gewesen
zu sein also man zum beispiel yoga nur
durch youtube-videos lernen dass die
verletzungsgefahr deutlich höher ist als
wirklich von den menschen also soviel
könnt ihr aus diesem youtube-video
mitnehmen youtube videos helfen nicht
immer ok aber was ist jetzt mit special
sachen wie er will yoga sei das beste
freundin und meine kollegin dieser so
viele rohr macht regelmäßig er wie yoga
hat immer davon geschwärmt wie cool das
ist und das ist so spaß macht und das
sieht das vor hilft im alltag
runterzukommen deswegen hatte ich große
erwartungen kam dann da rein und das war
ein riesen studio und von der decke hin
so seile und ich war so ok alles klar
ich hoffe ich spreche heute hier nicht
das genick
zu rwe jura gibt es wie ihr euch
sicherlich denken könnt bisher gar keine
forschung wahrscheinlich wird sich das
so schnell auch nicht ändern es ist
generell ein problem das es kaum
forschungsgelder gibt für yoga forschung
viele dieser studien sind von privaten
verbänden finanziert wie zum beispiel
vom berufsverband der yogalehrenden in
deutschland und das sehe ich natürlich
sehr kritisch natürlich
interessensgruppen studie unterstützen
haben sie immer natürlich die
möglichkeit des wechsels und liebt
auftreten was wir immer machen was auch
den der videos sind überrascht wie sehr
stark zu mit vertreten hat ist es das
komplette studiendesign die
studiendurchführung die studie der
austria interpretation oder
irgendwelchen komplett bei uns liebt das
ist also der usa warnt in keiner phase
der
studienplanung durch junge auswertung
mitredet und über diese studien hinaus
haben wieder darf kein persönliches
interesse an ich bin selbst ein
überlebender ich will dein geld damit
also wir veröffentlichen
größtenteils in konventionellen
zeitschriften sondern wir uns da hast du
dich komplett der begutachtung der
kollegen der kritik stellen das muss man
tatsächlich auch zugestehen also viele
dieser studien sind wirklich in
ordentlichen angesehenen journal
publiziert und wurden auch von anderen
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern geprüft es spricht
zumindest aus meiner sicht nichts
dagegen es einfach mal auszuprobieren
denn das yoga richtig angewendet stress
reduzieren kann so viel kann man
sicherlich festhalten und dann ist es
auch gut dass es so viele sehr
verschiedene yoga form gibt wo jeder
sein stil finden kann von sehr
spirituell bisher sportlich denn wichtig
ist dass man eine yoga form findet an
der man lange christ ich spaß hat denn
ein tadel sicherlich aus ihrem
selbstversuch gelernt nach einer
yogastunde ist man auch nichts denn
das spüre ich jetzt nein letzten die
anderen sauerstoffmangel yoga am
coolsten also es hat auch spaß gemacht
richtig diese übung auszuprobieren das
team war hat auch super nett alle aber
die anderen teams waren auch alle
wandelt also ich habe gelernt alle leute
die yoga machen
mein learning also ich finde die yoga
forschung zeigt vor allem eins die
wirkung scheint hier nicht an bestimmten
yoga raten oder yoga posen zu liegen
dafür ist er viel zu vielfältig ich
denke es geht vielmehr um einen
lebensstil um stressreduktion um
achtsamkeit und bewegung um vielleicht
auch gesündere ernährung das kann man
mit yoga sicherlich hinbekommen aber
bestimmt doch anders sei es jetzt durch
sport oder durch
regelmäßige teezeremonien schreib doch
mal in die kommentare was für
erfahrungen ihr mit yoga habt oder ob er
vielleicht irgendwelche anderen freizeit
tipps habt für ein entspannteres leben
dann können sich nämlich die anderen
davon inspirieren lassen und wenn ihr
vorschläge habt ihr was saadet in
zukunft als selbstversuch testen kann
dann schreibt es bitte auch gerne in die
kommentare unter dem hashtag stand
saadet und jetzt kommt noch die
versprochene atemübung wir sollten der
stressige situation ihr wollt ein paar
mal tief durchatmen durch die nase euch
auf den atem konzentrieren weil es nicht
ganz einfach ist helfen euch eure zwei
finger da könnt ihr immer abwechselnd
ein nasenloch zu halten durch das andere
konzentriert tief ein und ausatmen die
kleine körperliche hilfestellung macht
es viel einfacher sich auf den atem zu
konzentrieren wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
noch eure andere hand auf ihren bauch
legen und darauf achten dass die luft
richtig rein strömt und sich der bauch
hebt und senkt wir sehen uns nächste
woche und bis dahin bleibt entspannt